first of all before I get started I got
to thank everyone who apparently thinks
I'm special enough to have watched The
Avengers a week before it comes out in
the country of our forefathers to the US
of A in which I live that being said I'm
not special the Avengers comes out next
week in America I get to see it next
week I will review it by next weekend
until then I will try to entertain you
with reviews for popcorn flicks like the
movie safe
[Music]
safe I like saying it all epic like that
right so the movies safe stars Jason
Statham and it involves him kicking a
lot of ass right there I was like all
right transporter number 28 let's go I
knew exactly what I was in for for the
movie safe
however holy [ __ ] it surprised me I said
when the movie safe there's this little
Chinese girl and she's really good with
numbers hey that's not a stereotype
totally is the Chinese mobs using her
for pretty much a human book keep she
knows all the numbers of the businesses
they dealings they were like all right
memorized this number all right now go
here and then the Russians kidnap her
and then she's on the run from everybody
and then jason statham comes across her
path and he needs to protect her cuz
Jason Statham is a guy who was really
down on his luck he has nothing to live
for us when he sees his little girl in
trouble he's like alright that gives me
something to do after that it gives him
something to live for so you have Jason
Statham protecting this girl and then
you have the Chinese mob the Russian mob
and the cops all coming after them cops
are all like corrupt and [ __ ] then Jason
Statham gets to kick a lot of ass and we
all love seeing that and I expected that
in a movie like this but he really kicks
ass like you know Liam Neeson from
taking kind of we're like yeah I
wouldn't cross this guy he's taking out
armies of mobsters what am i grabs about
the movies really the shaky-cam there's
a lot of shaky-cam in this movie but the
sound effects really make up for it
shaky-cam sure and you're like oh I
can't focus can't focus but when you
hear bones starting to pop you're like I
know what's happening though that's
clearly the sound of teeth hitting the
ground thanks sound effect guy and the
gunshots in this movie sound really good
too when the gun goes off you're all Bob
yeah Dolby Digital baby yeah that's a
Glock that's when bones get broken that
sounds awesome when feet hit faces that
sounds awesome when fists hit faces
that's awesome when guns go off that's
awesome when cars hit cars that's
awesome it all sounds really good and
the movies as long as it needs to be -
it's about an hour and a half long if it
were any longer than that it'd be like
alright don't try to be something you're
not
we're any shorter than that I'd be like
what I pay to see a movie that short
chimpanzee when I was going into this
movie I knew what I was getting into but
I got a lot more than I thought I would
this movie is a good kick-ass movie is
it original no just think of it as like
you know terminator he has to protect a
little kid but instead of one terminator
you have two groups of mobsters and
corrupt cops all going out for the kids
that's not bad as far as Jason Statham
action movies go this is one of the
better ones for sure I will say safe is
a good time no alcohol acquired in a
world of cliche Jason Statham action
movie transporter number 38 the movie
safe surprised the hell out of me so
your favorite Jason Statham
action-movie what is it comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to say more
remember though next week Avengers
[Music]